alone hello my name is Margaret and I'm
Hector we live in Brazil and have come
to explore Germany's romantic road by
campervan the motorways in Germany are
fantastic the romantic road is really
special simply wonderful
we're now in bad merican time we would
like to discover the beauty of this
romantic town fantastic I didn't know
how beautiful this town is the houses
the decor the paintings the Germans the
flowers the flowers the people aren't in
a rush life here seems really relaxed
careful they can attack you for us this
is wonderful pretty it's like going back
in time experiencing the traditions
these nostalgic places these little
towns and their charming inhabitants
for me it's the nicest way to travel
good value to you can cook instead of
going to a restaurant and if you don't
fancy a place you don't have to stay
you're constantly on the move and
driving on Moda
constant MNT você pode Ypres oughta
cidade de otro canto we're spending the
night at this parking lot it costs just
three euros it's fine and we're right in
the centre of ruts pork
boy this bridge is so famous it reminds
me of the Charles Bridge in Prague
because how beautiful
he's simply unbelievable I'm lost for
words
amazing fantastical we're bidding
farewell to the Romantic Road here we
love Germany I live in